[موسيقى]
هو من المخرجين الذين يحرصون على الدقه
التاريخيه والعلميه في افلامهم قدر
الامكان لذلك لا اعتقد ان هذا الفيلم فيه
مشاكل كثيره يعني حتى بعض الامور التي
ربما يعني راها غريبه المشاهد ساذكرون
مثلا مساله التفاحه الخضراء لن اذكر
تفاصيل ولكن مساله التفاحه الخضراء التي
وردت في الفيلم هي حقيقيه وليست مجرد تخيل
او او كتابه دراميه يعني هي بالفعل حصلت
لذلك لن نستطيع لا برايي لا استطيع لا
احاسب هذا الفيلم على اخطاء تاريخيه بوجود
اسم نولد
لان هذا الفيلم وزير الذاتيه ونون بالنسبه
اليه اسره الذاتيه لا تروى عن الشخصيه
ولكن ترى من خلال الشخصيه لذلك اعتمد
كتابا مختلف عن السائد في هذا في هذه
النوعيه من الافلام يعني كتب
السيناريو من خلال وجهه نظر الشخصيه
الرئيسيه يعني هذا الامر اشاد يعني اشاد
به العديد من الكتاب السيناريو في هولندا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لليابان فهي اجلت القرار بشان عرض
هذا الفيلم لا تاخذ قرارا بعد ربما تنتظر
المرور
ذكرى هيروشيما ونجازاكي الذي هي في اول
شهر اغسطس لتاخذ هذا القرار ولكن اعتقد ان
هناك امر قد يؤثر ايضا على هذا القرار وهي
حمله كانت للناشطين يابانيين على مواقع
التواصل لفتره الانظار هي كانت ضد
التنا ول
السيء والمسيء والساخر
لهذه الماساه من خلال حمله باربن
باربنهايمر التي حدثت الملصقات
الى الاعتذار ربما ربما هذا الامر قد يؤثر
على عرض
[موسيقى]
هذا امر طبيعي يعني في هذه النوعيه من
الافلام الروائيه ليست افلام وثائقيه
المشكله تكون عندما تكون هذه الاخطاء
جسيمه يعني فيها تشويه لحقائق او لشخصيات
او يعني دائما استفدت درامي يضطر الى يعني
التعامل بشكل مختلف مع الاحداث والشخصيات
يعني مثلا بان نختصر مجموعه شخصيات في
شخصيه واحده فاذا يعني دائما الاعمال هذه
الاعمال يتم الغض النظر على هذه المربح
لانه هناك الرساله يراد ايصالها وافكار
ايضا معالجه لذلك لا يتم التركيز على هذه
الاخطاء الذي كانت جسيمه بالفعل ومشوهه